my first stop in also our weekend was
the Jorden pop-up shop where I hooked up
with Dez marzack
he's my homeboy from college and the
global director of advertising for the
Jordan place these are all the models
that he wore during all-star weekend man
Oh Jordan eleven uh that's the Holy
Roller yeah that's the one then maybe oh
I love a good 13 even well this was a
good three-year run where my mom's
finances were exposed she was like if
you want this one we can't do the next
five Sam here
take me back so when you were a kid you
were Jordan fan as well what was the
original plan what did you want to play
with them did you wanna know no wasn't
that good me neither straight-up
okay though I had to figure out a
different way in the game okay and I was
always in love with the Jordan
commercials man this is amazing I'm
overwhelmed right now with excitement
I'll tell you what this is birthday
weekend okay lotion did going down okay
come on down check them out cool my man
okay so dad's just invited me to Michael
Jordan's birthday party on the real when
you're a mature black man in America
you can't show excitement get to play it
cool like o MJ is party I'll see if I
have time but I want you to know inside
I was losing my adjacent
I was on the way excited
okay Jordan 20 tonight I don't know what
sauce I want to hit him with so I hit
him with the Space Jam remind him of
this Bugs Bunny experience when he saved
the world
give you I remind them of the 96 finals
when it killed off Gary Payton but maybe
Gary's there and Gary doesn't wanna be
reminded of that day so I don't want to
eat them want to see me do I hit him
with all white who does cocaine at the
party so I hit him with a throwback Oh
should I go black-tie like the Oscars I
want to be so clean but Michael Jordan
has to be like who's that guy hi I'm Jan
Davis this is les is my plus one
we're here to celebrate the birth of
Michael Jeffrey Jordan thank you yeah
we're on the list the piece of the big
deal people part important people
personally yeah I'm not nervous I
normally talk this way our cameras were
not allowed inside so from this point oh
I got a bootleg this deploring
Michael Jordan is not here LeBron is not
here I'm deadliest please hear my good
Jordan is officially here I'm nervous he
just there was such a Russell Westbrook
Charles Opeth in the building I get his
hand up Michael numerous times we
haven't met but like there's way up
there like my friends already so I'm
going to meet him I'm going back in
there I went to meet with his role he
needs too much to the hood and the
achievement for me tenacity and I was
right there so close I could smell
Michaels Michael Jordan Cologne but
do it I couldn't say what's up
[Applause]